when I did the Grinch I was literally
the makeup was like being buried alive
every day then Brian Grazer came in
being the Fix-It man and uh came up with
a brilliant idea which was to hire a
gentleman who is trained to uh uh to
teach CIA operatives uh how to endure
torture and so
everything you see and if you're
freaking out and you start to spiral
downward uh turn the television on
change a pattern have someone you know
come up and smack you in the head
um you know punch yourself in the leg so
it was or or smoke smoke as much as you
possibly can so I was this Grinch
sitting
team
and this giant cigarette holder so so
the yak hair wouldn't go on fire
it was horrifying wow it was horrifying
it was just like it's for the kids it's
for the kids
thank you